hi drew oh hoda i mean you
are it's amazing that you wrote now a
book
that you know we can look at every
morning because we also watch you on
television every morning
and even when you have to deliver the
facts and it's our civic duty to
understand what's going on in the world
you still exude positivity and hope
and you have been kind enough to bring
people
into your life and your experience which
just makes us feel like we know you all
the more
and then that comes back and like folds
into the omelette so when we're watching
you every day it's like
okay i know this person i feel safe with
this person i trust this person
this person is a human being they're
full of grace
and it's just an amazing line that you
manage to straddle every day
you just said it folds into the omelette
i could listen
to you all day that's so beautiful
um and thank you because i think you
know what's funny sometimes it's easy to
share the good stuff in your life but
you don't want to share the crummy stuff
and you know having kids was a great joy
for me and sharing that
was effortless for me
when i was sick at one point when i was
working at nbc with breast cancer
i was determined to put that deep in my
pockets and not share that because i
didn't want to be that person
and i remember distinctly meeting
somebody on a plane
and he asked me why i was wearing a
compression sleeve on the plane
and i told him that i had cancer but i
said to him i hope
that's not how you remember me and he
said
what's wrong with you he said having
cancer is part of you it's like working
at nbc or getting married or
graduating college he said let me give
you some advice and you can go to sleep
and he said don't hog your journey it's
not just for you
and i sat in that moment with this
complete stranger and realized that i
had just
changed the path of my life like what
good is it he said you can put your
stuff deep in your pockets and take it
to your grave or you can help someone
like those are your choices a or b
choose
and when he said that i was so struck by
the fact that i wanted to hide the bad
parts of my life
and suddenly i felt lifted and lighter
and i mentioned it at work when i'd kept
it a secret and i said it out loud
and then it was and then all of a sudden
it was i found that it really was
helping people
it shaped me it didn't define me but you
can it can you can still help people
with it
well and the way that you
are sharing your life and your journey
it means so much to people
and the other day you just announced
that you filled out paperwork to adopt a
third child
we did we did may i ask what inspired
that decision
you know what i was sitting with joel
who by the way has a grown daughter
who just graduated law school so know
where we are here
and i said to him like we have a lot of
love in this house
i said do we have space for more love i
said yes we do
i said would our family be enhanced yes
it would
you know are there children who need us
to yes there
are every answer was yes look it's not
in our hands now
we fill out the paperwork and say you
know it's in god's hands like come what
may
i just know that your heart's ability to
expand
blows my mind you can fit so much love
in there it's true what i had all olive
and then i found out
you know i was gonna have frankie i was
like oh how does this work and then it
just
your heart does get bigger and i know
that you've touched countless women with
your story
in fact um we have a little surprise for
you if that's okay
um one of them has a very special
message for you actually
take a look i'm a mom to three by
adoption
asher who's five zane two and zara
one and i can remember hearing how to
say when the child that's meant to be
yours
finally finds you it's as if a puzzle
piece clicks into place and it's as if
they've always been with you always been
a part of you
it's as though she's speaking through
the camera to all of us
who've walked this journey i can
remember trying to meet hoda
to get our copy of i've loved you since
forever signed but as luck of mom of two
small kids would have it
nap time interfered and i couldn't get
to meet her
i just want her to know how much she
means to me and the adoption community
at large
and how amazing she is for speaking her
truth
and for being so open about this manner
of
family building thank you hold up we
love you
bye
um if it's okay i thought i could help
facilitate
a missed sliding doors moment hi
samantha
hi i'm so excited oh my god
this is awesome i know i'm almost crying
with you
oh my gosh choosing adoption man that's
awesome well i just have to say thank
you
drew for connecting us and what i've
been waiting for this opportunity to be
able to speak to you and tell you how
much
not only you mean to the adoption
community but how much your words have
had an impact on our lives you know your
words when you spoke your words and i
read them in print and i heard them in
your interview with sandra bullock and
i broke down into a puddle of tears
because when you talk about
the flood of emotion that you feel when
your child
finally finds you it took me back to the
moment asher was born
and again i was confronted with your
your words and
and i was inspired by them when we were
presented the opportunity to
adopt zara you know we had two kids we
thought we were done
two perfect little boys a little pair of
brothers and when zayn was seven weeks
old his birth mom texted me and said
guess what and i was like what do you
mean
and my husband and i had almost the same
conversation that you just spoke about
having with joel like
jeez i i we have love in our hearts for
three kids but can we do this i mean
zayn is seven weeks old he's not
sleeping he doesn't hold a bottle
he can't sit up on his own can we do
this and
we just heard your voice in our heads
you know when the perfect child that's
meant to be yours
finds you they will arrive right on time
and it doesn't matter
how old your next youngest is it doesn't
matter if you're in your 30s 40s or 50s
it doesn't matter
and your message of positivity and hope
just inspired
my family to be what it is today so
thank you thank you
man i'm gonna send you a book i know you
weren't at the book signing but i'm
gonna get you one okay
drew's gonna hook us up yes i will
happily be your liaison
thank you samantha for coming on and
sharing such beautiful
feelings and words with hoda thank you
so much thank you hoda for everything
you do
thank you samantha for what you just did
wow thank you
i love you i thank you so much and i'm
gonna love up on you every morning
because you know what also don't
this is something i've been telling
myself recently and until i got your
book i was searching for like poem a day
on apps and
it was sort of working but it wasn't i
asked myself
please don't look at your phone first
thing in the morning anymore
that cannot be your first thing you have
found the solve and the answer to a more
spiritual open-minded better intended
life
this really is important thank you drew
thank you hoda thank you so much
[Music]